- [Voiceover] Let's say
that we had a function
defined by the infinite series
so we're going to from
N equals one to infinity
and each term is going
to be X to the N plus one
over four to the N times N to the fourth
and we could even expand this out.
When N is equal to one this is going to be
X squared over four
times one to the fourth
so which is going to be four.
When X is equal to two this is going to be
X to the third power over four squared,
four squared times two to the fourth power
and we know this of course is 16 times 16
which would be 256 but I'll
just leave it like that for now.
Plus when X is three, this is
going to be X to the fourth
over four to the fourth power
times four to the fourth
which is really going to be
four to the eighth power
and we'll just keep going on
and on and on just to get a sense
of what this function would look like.
This function that's
defined by infinite series.
Now what I'm curious
about is for what X values
will this function
converge to finite values
or another way of thinking
about it let's come up
with the radius of convergence
or the interval of
convergence for this function.
Now since we've just been
talking about the ratio test
you might say, "Well, maybe
the ratio test is useful."
For what X values is this
thing going to converge
so let's apply the ratio test.
Let's take the limit, the
limit as N approaches infinity
of the absolute value
of the N plus oneth term
over the Nth term.
For this particular case
this is going to be the limit
as N approaches infinity
so the N plus oneth term,
I'll do this in orange so it'll be
X to the N plus one plus one.
So it's going to be X to the N plus two,
over four to the N plus one,
times N plus one to the fourth power
and we're going to divide
that by the Nth term
which is just going to
be X to the N plus one
over four to the N times N to the fourth
which of course is going
to be the same thing
as the limit as N approaches infinity of,
I can just copy and paste this, of this
so copy and paste that times
the reciprocal of this.
We're dividing by a rational expression,
that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal.
Times four to the N, N to the fourth
over X to the N plus one power.
Actually let me just clean
this up a little bit.
I can re-simplify this.
Well X to the, let me
get another color here
so X to the N plus two divided
by X to the N plus one,
well N plus two minus N plus
one is just going to be one
so this is just going to simplify
to an X in the numerator.
Then let's see, four to the N divided by
four to the N plus one so
this is the same thing as,
this is the same if we divide
the numerator and denominator
by four to the N, this is going to be one
and this is just going to be a four.
This is going to simplify
to, I don't know,
I forgot my absolute value
signs, don't want to do that
so let's keep my absolute value signs here
the whole time.
This is going to be equal to the limit
as N approaches infinity
of the absolute value of,
we're going to have X, N to
the fourth in the numerator
so let me write that down.
We're going to have X times N
to the fourth in the numerator
and in the denominator
I'm going to have four
times N plus one to the fourth.
Well what's that going to be?
Well if you expand out N
plus one to the fourth,
it's going to be N to the fourth
plus a bunch, a bunch of terms
and a bunch of lower degree terms,
this is going to be highest degree term
so if you distribute the four,
it's going to be four N to the fourth
plus a bunch of lower degree terms.
Let me write it that
way so it's over four,
I'll use the same colors.
Four N to the fourth,
plus a bunch of lower degree terms.
Now, what's the limit as N
approaches infinity here?
Well, we have the same,
we want to look at the
highest degree terms.
We want to look at the N to the fourth,
the fourth degree terms
and so it's really going to
be the coefficient on this
and one way to think about it
if you divide the numerator
and the denominator
both by N to the fourth,
these are the only terms,
you're going to have an X in the numerator
and the denominator
you're going to have four
and all these others
terms are going to divided
by some power of N.
As your limit approaches,
as N approaches infinity
all the other terms are going to zero
and all you're going to have left
in the denominator is a
four and X in the numerator.
This right over here, the
limit as N approaches infinity
is going to be X over four
or I should say the absolute
value of X over four.
It's going to be equal
to the absolute value
of X over the absolute
value of X over four.
Now we can apply the ratio test
or I guess we're always applying him
but now we can really test,
do the test part of it
and the ratio test tells us
that if this limit right over here,
as long as it evaluates to something
that is less than one, then
our series will converge.
We just have to say that this
expression right over here
has to be less than one.
Our function is going to
converge to finite values
as long as the absolute
value of X over four
is less than one and this is
dividing the absolute value of,
or the absolute value of X over four
is going to be the same thing
as the absolute value of X
divided by four so it's four is positive
so that just has to be less than one.
Multiply both sides by four,
won't change the equality
since four is positive
so you're going to have
the absolute value of X
has to be less than four.
Just like that we have defined
the radius of convergence.
This right over here is
the radius of convergence
for our function or for
our infinite series,
radius of convergence.
Or if we wanted to write
that same information
as an interval of
conversions, we would say
that X has to be less than four
or greater than negative four.
This is the same
information right over here,
express this way, this is
the interval of convergence.
These are the X values for which
this original function here
is going to converge to finite values.